hi in this video we'll talk about
zika virus infection which is a mosquito
bone viral infection and the common
symptoms are very similar to
a viral fever like headache fever chills
etc so here is a fact sheet for zika
virus infection
many people might show mild symptoms
while other might not even show any
symptoms it is especially dangerous for
pregnant woman and her baby your doctor
might take blood or urine sample to
get a test done for zika there is no
specific medication
yet for zika neither there is any
vaccination
and it is not as infectious as covid19
so
zika is generally spread by the mosquito
bite
such as it is in egyptian or
other species of aedes mosquito let me
remind you that this species of mosquito
is also responsible for the spread of
dengue which is another virus
viral infection now the mosquitoes
are very active during the daytime
so there are multiple ways by which zika
infection
could transmit one of the way is blood
transfusion
second way if you are affected by zika
virus
then your partner might get affected
via zika virus while doing sex
and zika can be passed from infected
mother
to its baby now let's say
you are in a crowd and you are infected
with
zika virus so this
it is mosquito might bite you
and with its blood mail might carry the
virus
and while it is in biting another person
that particular person might get
infected
so from one person to another person it
gets
transmitted with the help of this
mosquito
so saving ourselves from mosquito bite
is a good way of prevention
recently in india 14 cases are detected
in kerala and several cases are detected
in west bengal
inside india so it's kind of worrisome
whether it's going to create another
pandemic-like situation
but let me remind you zika is not as
infectious
as kovid but the concern still remains
because india is kind of like a
hot and humid climate so
mosquitoes are prevalent in many states
across
india and if mosquitoes are more
the probability that these kind of virus
bone
diseases would be spreading is more so
we need to be very cautious
about mosquito bites especially during
the monsoon
before even this around 2015
there was a report of zika outbreak
in brazil and during that
outbreak there was incidence of
microcephaly
in brazil microcephaly is a fancy term
for babies who are born with
abnormally small head generally the
baby's head would look like this
and microcephaly would lead
to a reduction in the head size and the
baby would
look somewhat like this and in this
video we'll
describe how zika virus can induce
microcephaly-like symptoms
so let's talk about the general symptoms
of zika virus infection
so it's very normal it's very likely
that zika virus would give you fever
headache rashes in arms joint pain
and these symptoms are pretty
overlapping with any
viral fever like kovid like
rhinoviruses etc
now zika virus is a cousin of
dengue both of them belong to the family
of flavivirity
and both of them are transmitted via
eddie's egyptian mosquito
so zika virus can infect several cell
types
in our body ranging from brain cells
such as astrocytes
skin cells dendritic cells which is an
immune cell
and even sperms more importantly
zika virus can transmit
from mother to the fetus that means it
can cross placenta
which is a big concern
zika virus is a complicated virus
so if we cut a cross section across zika
virus
we can see the capsid proteins and
inside the capsid protein
there is positive sense rna
now zika virus enters the cell by
attaching to specific receptor present
on the cell
and it the cell involves the zika virus
inside the cell the mrna genome
of the zika virus is translated
which would lead to production of
several viral proteins which is
necessary for viral particle assembly
and the life processes of that virus
now this particular mrna with the help
of
another template gets replicated
and many copies of these genome
is generated later on these genome
and the viral proteins are assembled and
a new
new viral particle leaves the cell
and in this process the cells get
injured
now let's talk about how our immune
system
can fight back zika virus infection
so our immune system is pretty
intelligent
so whenever there is a zika infection
our immune system
or any other cell type in our body
secretes
one type of messenger known as
interferons
these interferons are alarming signal
which tells the nearby cell
that there is a viral infection so get
ready for combat
so the nearby cell after receiving this
information
would be more ready to
fight these infectious viruses
so this is how our body fights back
generally
other than that our immune cells
produce antibody against zika viruses
so these antibody would coat the zika
virus
all over and several cell types which
can recognize these antibodies such as
neutrophils macrophages natural killer
cells dendritic cells
would ultimately engulf these virus and
eliminate them
from our body this is how our body
fights back
especially the concern is when zika
virus can cross placenta it can enters
the fetal circulation and it
it is known that zika virus affects the
brain cells let me be more specific
so let us talk about how zika virus can
cause
microcephaly microcephaly is a birth
defect which is characterized by
abnormally smaller head size
and the head size is kind of
significantly reduced in these zika
induced microcephaly patients
so it has been shown now that how
zika virus can possibly cause
microcephaly
and the answer came from human stem cell
derived
brain organoids now brain organoids are
mini brains
which kind of shows signatures like a
fetal brain
so brain organoids would mimic fetal
brain development
now if zika virus
is added in these organoid culture
while developing then the zika infected
organoid
look abruptly diminished in size
and upon molecular examination
scientists have
found that the stem cells
we generally amplify and form
neurons in the brain are really affected
in these zika virus infected organoids
so the stem cells generally
amplify their number and then produce
neurons
but these stem cells are highly affected
by zika virus
which lead to death of these stem cells
and as a result cortical thickness
is reduced which can explain
why zika virus can lead to
microcephaly or smaller head size
so let's summarize what we have learned
so far
first of all let me tell you there is no
vaccine for zika
so not getting zika
is the biggest concern right now
prevention is always better than cure so
so far we have learned that zika virus
is a mosquito bone viral disease
we also learned how zika infection
can spread in human body what are the
cell types that get affected
we also learned how our body fight back
zika
and finally we understood
how stem cell derived organoid helped
the scientists to unravel the mystery
that how zika
can cause microcephaly even if
we know how zika can affect our brain
development
but we don't have a treatment for this
yet
i hope this video was useful to you if
you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe
you can also support me in patreon and
if you're an indian viewer you can
scan this qr code and help me with bim
upi
a small contribution from your site is
always appreciated
thank you for listening and do let me
know in the comment how you like my
video thank you